on est prêt à continuer d'être en leader
pour les vols vers l'espace
Ottawa ouvre un nouveau chapitre de
l'histoire spatiale canadienne dans un
premier temps le lancement d'engins
spatiaux du secteur privé tel que des
satellites sera permis en solde canadien
sur une période de trois ans l'autre
gouvernement veut encourager et
accueillir ce type d'investissement et
d'innovation du secteur privé ici au
Canada nous avons un secteur spatial au
Canada qui est très robuste et qui est
pas mal holistique par contre il nous
manquait ce morceau les engins spatiaux
sécuritaires et durables pourront être
propulsés le ministre des Transports
assure qu'il travaillera avec les autres
ministères pour élaborer des exigences
réglementaires des normes de sécurité et
des conditions pour obtenir un permis on
a quelque chose de spécial à offrir par
rapport à d'autres pays le Canada a une
position géographique qui permet de
varier les inclinaisons orbitales et
surtout de viser le nord de notre
planète ce qui veut dire qu'au lieu de
faire une rotation parallèle à
l'équateur les engins spatiaux peuvent
plus facilement prendre une trajectoire
longitudinale du Pôle Nord au pôle Sud
il y a un grand désir pour
des endroits pour lancer le satellite
comme ça et puis le Cardin est vraiment
positionné parfaitement pour offrir ça
les portes du pays serait aussi ouverte
pour les lancements de compagnie
étrangères mais avec un bémol la
politique étrangère de notre pays doit
être prise en ligne de compte d'ailleurs
un premier port de lancement est déjà en
construction à kenso en Nouvelle-Écosse
il faudra sans doute attendre jusqu'en
2024 pour assister au premier lancement
en orbite à partir de la côte Est du
pays ici Carla Oliveira Radio-Canada
Montréal